now i have to pause everybody we haven't
done one of these in a couple of weeks
we're about to show you a clip from the
view everybody make sure you're in your
chair if you need the booze grab it real
quick uh here is whoopi uh and uh you
know it's her body don't touch her body
but i will tell you this is my body
and nobody you you know you've got
people telling me i gotta wear a mask or
don't wear a mask or do this everybody
wants to tell me what to do but you
won't let me make my decision about my
body you are not
the person to make that decision my
doctor and my self and my child that's
who makes the decision and one of the
things i really want to point out before
we go is the reason abortion came about
women in this country
lived forever with it being illegal
okay
women when they decide
something is not right for them they're
going to take it into their own hands
well we got tired of tripping over women
in bathrooms public bathrooms who were
giving themselves abortions because
there was nowhere safe nowhere clean
nowhere to go this law came about
because people wanted people to have
somewhere safe and somewhere clean it
has nothing to do with your religion
this is not a religious issue this is a
human issue if you care about me as a as
a human being
you should know three things getting an
abortion is not easy making that
decision is not easy it's not something
people do lightly it's not something
that you can just do it it is a hard
awful decision that people make and if
you don't have the wherewithal to
understand that to start this
conversation with i know how hard this
must be for you if you're starting it by
telling me i'm gonna burn in hell then
you're not looking out for me as a human
being whether i subscribe to your
religion or not and that is not okay we
will be right back well you can already
see where i'm going with this one right
i mean are we laying it on a little
thick because this is not what whoopi
and the other nut bag harpies were
saying a couple weeks ago when it came
to other people's bodies and other
people's doctors and other people's
medical decisions here is whoopi yeah so
we had to make a law to make you
understand this is how we do it and i
just feel like look i understand you
don't want to wear a mask i don't want
to wear a mask either but i also don't
want to be concerned when i'm outside
that you didn't do what you were
supposed to do yeah and when i look what
12 and under those 12 and others they
don't get a choice yeah no for that
reason alone this should be mandated
because the little ones
you know they're hoping somebody will
say
mommy or daddy will say yeah come on
we're gonna go get this because i gotta
tell you the seven year old that i live
with
it's like is it am i going to be okay at
school yeah yeah and i have to lie yeah
when i think you're saying
they really make this [ __ ] too easy you
know these people are just so ridiculous
so she wanted other people to be
injected she wanted other people to be
masked she was seemingly very concerned
about seven-year-olds she's not very
concerned about seven month births uh
pregnancies let's say uh but okay fine
we could have done a gajillion clips of
that or of every one of those women
saying the exact same thing obviously uh
here was some uh audio uh about how the
biden administration really is in some
ways even more radical than what the
senators from the democrat states want
when it comes to abortion
first let me say the president's
position is that we need to codify roe
and that is what he has long called on
congress to act on what is also true is
that there has been a vote on the
women's health protection act which
would do exactly that and there were not
even enough votes even if there was no
filibuster to get that
did you get what she just said right
there they want to push this thing
through to codify roe but even with the
filibuster if they blow up the
filibuster right and they only need 50
votes
that they still don't have enough that
means there aren't even enough democrats
to do the radical thing that the biden
administration wants to do so what do we
have to do people in summation we got to
keep exposing these people we got to not
forget what the real issues are we have
to mock them when it's appropriate and
and we have to just build a better
society and and if this is just the
continued sort of
devolution of of where america is at
that we will just live in sort of very
different countries even if
geographically will still be one country
i think that's kind of okay and maybe
that's what this really is all about
because this thing in essence is about
states rights and it's just going to be
super
different california is just going to be
a giant
cesspool of high tax high regulation an
abortion fest and a crime fest and a
drug fest and a homeless fest and then
there'll be other places where it'll be
there'll be some room for disagreement
and there'll be pro-life people and
pro-choice people that live there and
we'll have the moderate positions of 15
weeks and we'll have common sense from
our leaders and things like that that's
it but i'm going to continue covering
all the nonsense from the administration
i'm not going to only focus on this
issue
obviously we'll we'll hit it when we
have to and i'll have to when they start
burning cities and everything else we'll
have to cover
some of that stuff but we're not going
to let them get away with it and mostly
i'm going to try to focus on on the
better things that we can build